natanyahou warta mexicaine vivante à
paris bonsoir tania web ça vous est
confiné comme tout le monde à paris que
vous inspirent ces chiffres encore
plutôt clément on va dire ça comme ça
pour pour le mexique ça s'explique alors
ce qu'il faut savoir bonsoir d'abord ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que les mexique
à une quinzaine de jours de retard on va
dire par rapport à l'espagne vous en
avait parlé tout à l'heure et pour
l'instant on a recensé plus d'une
centaine des cas de malades 118 cas
aujourd'hui je crois et il ya eu un mort
de deux récents c'est une personne
diabétique donc évidemment les
populations fragiles le diabète au
mexique est une préoccupation
voilà les il ya une sorte d'attentisme
et les présidences se veut on va dire
rassurant il prépare les choses mais la
population effectivement commencent à
s'inquiéter alors ils préparent les
choses effectivement il ya l'exemple
chinois européens
donc retour sur expérience certainement
et puis l'épidémie de grippe porcine en
2009 elle a laissé des traces au mexique
certainement oui absolument tout le
monde a en tête l'épisode de 2009 où il
y a eu vraiment de la même manière à peu
près à la même époque
ben tout de suite des mesures prises par
le président de l'époque felipe calderon
qui a décidé effectivement des prolonger
les vacances et de prendre des mesures
de fermeture comme actuellement france
aux tous débuts fermeture des bars
discothèques restaurants et la vie s'est
arrêtée
effectivement à mexico s'était vraiment
palpable avec les embouteillages qui lit
habituellement c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment très très présent dans la
tête de tous les mexicains et c'est pour
cela que quelque part le
la préoccupation des mexicains des vans
un petit peu le ton rassurant du
président puisque les gens ont ça en
tête et ils commencent à s'inquiéter
avec déjà des achats on va dire de de
prévention si ce n'est de magnifiques et
est il une autre préoccupation c'est
effectivement la fragilité du système de
santé mexicain la fragilité du système
de santé ça veut dire quoi concrètement
les hôpitaux qui n'ont pas de moyens
également des mexicains qui seront
peut-être à l'instar des états unis
obligé de payer eux mêmes leurs soins
avec un système de santé très moyen très
voilà peu efficace peu efficace
oui alors d'après ce que j'ai pu lire de
près ce que j'essaie les systèmes
mexicains aujourd'hui actuellement
compte environ une 5000 lits dont la
moitié des systèmes de respiratoires je
sais pas comment ça s'appelle
techniquement il faut reporter ça au
nombre de la population mexicaine qui
est le double de la france donc pour à
peu près les mêmes nombres de 10 elle
est même nombre de systèmes de des
respirations donc plus les de la
couverture sociale on va dire qu'ils qui
n'a pas de comparaison avec ce qui peut
se faire en europe et en france
notamment
donc voilà ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut prendre un compte pour pour le
mexique
c'est une fragilité j'en reviens à cette
expérience d'épidémie de grippe porcine
en 2009
selon vous quelles seront justement les
premières mesures un petit peu fortes
prises par le gouvernement si l'épidémie
devaient s'accélérer au mexique ce
serait le confinement strict des tests
systématiques contrairement à la france
par exemple
alors pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu de
mesures de prises pour des tests à
grande échelle
les présidences c'est vraiment rassurant
on l'a taxé parfois même de prendre les
choses avec décontraction on va dire
avec sa conférence de presse matinale
qu'il tient tous les jours et dans
laquelle il a même évoqué ses grigris
pour se protéger c'est un petit peu de
la provocation de sa part évidemment
mais il annonce que des mesures qu'un
plan est en cours de préparation que
tout est prêt que le mexique est préparé
mais les mexicains sont vraiment
préoccupé et et peut-être que comme ça
c'est passé par dans des épisodes dans
l'histoire du mexique notamment les
tremblements de terre de 1985 ou plus
récemment et bien c'est la société
civile qui va un peu prendre les devants
sur les mesures prises par les
politiques pour basse et j'ai essayé de
production de protéger la difficulté au
mexique c'est que comme vous le savez il
ya toute une partie d'économie
informelle avec beaucoup de personnes
qui vivent vraiment au jour le jour et
pour lesquels ça va être vraiment très
difficile et voilà merci en tout cas on
a bien compris merci
tania warta d'avoir été avec nous